how does one like you they don't know
like come become you know who you are
today with your ideas tell us tell us
get your ideas from um I don't what do
you mean can you what do you mean by
that question exactly what I ask you
like how did you come up with the ideas
that you have today was it well I didn't
come up with them per se I mean a lot of
my ideas being an anarchist
um are historically you know I did
something called the anarchist handbook
which we discussed it was a collection
of uh the tradition of anarchism and
this tagline for the book is the Black
Flag comes in many colors because there
are different schools of anarchism but
basically anarchism is the understanding
that uh political Authority is
illegitimate and you do not speak for me
and everything else is just application
so when you're saying enter we've
interviewed Libertarians Democrats
Republicans progressives I for me this
is my first Anarchist well Dave Smith's
been on he's a very failed eggest yeah
he's more Olympic field I like that yeah
but he's a very failed actor he's your
most frequent guest I think you said
yeah when we did the lockdowns we did
yeah I think he's a stud but stuck okay
okay
listen I know there's that line but you
got to wake up pretty in the morning but
the convince me that Dave Smith's a stud
you really got to wake me up early in
the morning six hours of sleep Dave's a
six hours yeah you know in his in his
mind that's a stud and by the way you're
talking to a guy that also respects
people who get proper ample amount of
sleep okay so he's part of the Ariana
Huffington Camp you're gonna ask the
question Dave sleepy Dave well anyway so
you're you're unique so for I guess part
of Pat's questioning yeah you're a nice
guy
so for you you're probably like I'm an
anarchist it's like I roll out of bed at
you know noon it's what I I do I'm an
anarchist I but for the most of the
people in the audience probably not too
familiar with what the the substantive
beliefs of Anarchy or when I hear
Anarchy I'm like this guy's a wild man
but you seem pretty you know nice guy so
explain what Anarchy is and why people
should maybe consider that for their
ideology well I remember when I was in
college we I was taking a bioethics
Course and there was this kind of chart
that spanned the the range of what the
bioethics range of ideas were and in one
chart one part of the chart was legalism
which is basically the idea that what
the government defines as moral is moral
and the other half is that antinomianism
which is the belief that it morals are
independent of the law and the the
author went on to say Well since No One
Believes In antidomianism it's somewhere
else in this chart well that is the
belief in antinomism that something is
not moral since simply because it's
legal and something is not immoral
simply because it's legal that morality
precedes law and that uh politicians or
you know anyone else who kinds tries to
assume Authority have to be held
accountable to a higher power but also
the belief that you know government
democracy all these things are
inherently illegitimate and can never be
made valid or coherent even so you're
saying there's a difference between
morality and legality yes I don't think
that's a particularly controversial
perspective of that aspect of anarchism
and then who how do you define morality
and who's who's the authority on
morality this is what the Bible is it
God is it Jesus is it Muhammad what do
you come with morale is it human
Muhammad
that's the Jew yes I really bet on the
wrong Bank on this one
um no I I morality is something Rand
Ironman talks about very frequently and
this again is independent of anarchism
morality is something that we all have
to deal with we have no choice we all
have to face moral issues on a daily
basis we may not tend to think of them
as moral like okay am I going to go to
the school to check up on how my kid's
doing or am I going to spend time at
business or am I going to be with my
mistress these are all moral questions
even though there may not be framed
maybe the last one most certainly would
be so the point being that morality and
our conscience is something that is
inescapable and there are very many
mechanisms uh promulgated by the
corporate press to try to make things
seem morally ambiguous or seem morally
uh Incorrect and this is just you know
one of the other many reasons why I and
so many other people not specifically
anarchists have so much contempt for
corporate journalists by the way just
search what is anarchy right anarcho
pacifism okay is a form of anarchism
which completely rejects the use of
violence in any form for any purpose
the main precedent was Henry David
Thoreau yes who uh through his work
Civil Disobedience influenced both Leo
Tolstoy and Mahatma Gandhi's advocacy of
non-violent resistance right so I think
when you and I talked last time I'm
trying to I asked I said would that be
possible today in America you were
pretty confident that it wouldn't be
hard to get there so if if we if we
wanted to if if you had it your way
let's just say today Michael malice wins
2024 election on nine hours of sleep how
am I running how am I running for office
I know you're not but let's just say if
you are okay and you're you're a you're
able to do certain policies that you
would like to implement in U.S what
would some of those policies be you mean
like what kind of guillotines there you
go that's one French Revolution Vibes
who goes first I I I I I I I mean I
don't okay great question this is what
happens when you wake me up early this
is what happens
because I do have a list no
um I do not believe the list I'm not
even really kidding I don't believe that
someone can ethically be a politician
and sir but to answer your question in a
different way no I'm not a pacifist and
the only policies I would be interested
in doing is to uh you know destroy as
many swaths of government as possible
and to have consequences for government
officials as much as possible for their
depravity
so get rid of so if you don't then the
government runs without having any
politicians and the people are managing
themselves with the laws and the
guidelines and the rules all of that
that's that's kind of it's not
necessarily matching themselves for
example if I go to like a department
store right there's a system of
governance in place I can no shirts no
shoes no Services something like that
there's some store will have you can
return things some stores have it you
can't return things so basically you
would have this kind of localized uh
excuse me very localized very
decentralized sense of governance
because there's this kind of myth that
uh anarchism is the idea of no rules but
that's not accurate at all if I go to
your house you know if you're having a
white party and I gotta wear white it's
certainly within your rights to say
you're not wearing white get the F out
of my house so it is you know it is
inescapable that someone is going to
have jurisdiction over certain areas the
point being to have someone insinuate
themselves as the state uh in between
these relationships is illegitimate
how does that look like so so let's so
so you're saying it would be
self-regulated like we would
self-regulate we do that now again I'm
here I I came at your time I am doing
your podcast I can't just do whatever I
want I'm following certain principles
and then if I don't at a certain point
you can either tell me to leave or if it
gets extreme you call security so this
is something that not only is not
hypothetical it's something we live 24 7
you know 365 days a year and uh
anarchism is you know voluntary
cooperation in exchange is the basis of
any healthy society and the problems
only come through public crime
governments or private crime criminals
so if that's the case we're we're right
now what country today is running on
that system so anarchism isn't a
location anarchism is a relationship so
anytime you have two people or two
organizations or two entities or more
where they have no semblance of
authority higher than them that is an
anarchist relationship and let me give
you a good example we don't have a world
government right so if an American I
apologize for this and if an American
kills the Canadian in Mexico who has
jurisdiction no one but they still have
some mechanism in place between the
three of them because every country is
in a state of anarchism toward every
other country so anarchism again isn't
like a place it's a relationship between
different entities how does that work in
interpersonal relationships so let's say
with a husband and wife or a business
husband's in charge that's it bottom
line uh it's the best answer I'm gonna
hear all day that's what Muhammad was
right
yeah okay so it's it almost sounds like
you sound like a pastor it's like you
know you got to have a relationship with
God it's what it is you know it's not a
Christianity is not a religion it's it's
a relationship with God you know Muslim
is not it's a relationship it's a
relationship but at the same time if you
say anarchy so if if because the way you
sound you sound super convincing okay
and and and you're a you're obviously
very sharp guy your history stuff you
you know guys coming up to you helping
out with writing you do such a good job
they thank you but they say please let's
make sure we don't have to say that you
did this because of your background and
what you believe in you're a very sharp
guy with your background you've been on
Rogan I don't know how many times you've
been on Rogue uh it's either eight or
six okay that's a lot of times to be on
Roku he pulled two episodes because we
had the n-word okay so E6 got it Anarchy
but but but okay so but when you sound
convincing if it's that convincing
Michael why aren't more people doing it
is it the argument
is I'll tell you I can ask you a
question yeah absolutely so there's an
essay in the anarchist handbook by Emma
Goldman and she gets into why the
majority cannot reason so the vast
majority of people are not capable of
rational discourse particularly when it
comes to politics so any kind of and
democracy exploits this uh first of all
they don't often have time but second
they often don't have the mental
capacity but again it's the popularity
of an idea is not at all uh Testament to
its veracity or lack of veracity if that
were true then the funniest show in
history would be how uh The Big Bang
Theory uh which of course I don't think
anyone will say with a straight face is
the case but that's the most popular
sitcom that that either now or has ever
been ridiculous so one of the there are
several reasons one is why it's not more
popular people in power especially those
who are in power illegitimately have an
enormous best interest and enormous
incentive to maintain their power and to
increase their power and for over a
century now uh the state has been
raising America's children as its own uh
taking them since now they want it
younger and younger and inculcating them
with ideas that if you received them for
the first time as an adult you would
regard as absurd but since you've been
kind of trained to accept them as
plausible since you're four or five
years old you don't even bat an eye when
you're the repeated to you as an adult
such as the idea that we all understand
here in this room maybe it's different
for the Canadian that aristocracy is
legitimate right just someone was born
to some King and now this guy is going
to some Queen and now this person is
going to have some kind of uh um
position to dictate terms of your life
take money from you this is crazy but
somehow if there's a lot of your
neighbors believe something that they
now as a group have the power to take
your freedoms away that is regard to
sanity it's in in the anarchist
perspective it's complete as completely
insane what was the first Anarchy
Community what was the first Anarchy
Community the for I don't know what you
would what you would consider the first
Anarchist I'm just Googling it right now
and I put Anarchy and it says list of
anarchist communities so pedios so which
one would be meaning because you said
it's not a country it's a relationship
right that's what you said again so
these little communities are very much
kind of the in the anarcho-capitalist
excuse me a narco-communist way and they
often didn't last very long yeah I guess
so but the idea of Anarchy what was the
first Inception of the idea of Anarchy
what year was that again it again zero
the year 5000 BC anarchism again is a
relationship so whenever you have people
interacting with each other without any
kind of sovereign or a ruler over them
that is an example of anarchism working
it's not a place and it's not a time
well so an example would be two friends
yeah here we go I'll give you some
examples okay ready here are some
examples stop Googling listen listen I'm
gonna read this to you I want to read
this idea Anarchy is a society without a
government okay okay it may also I don't
care what the computer says I'm just
because for me it's for smart guys like
you you don't need it I'm I'm trying to
get you know but I don't think Wikipedia
is I know let me just read this Michael
okay so Anarchy is a society without a
government it may also refer to society
or group of people that entirely rejects
a set hierarchy okay Anarchy was first
used in English dictionary in 1539 an
absence of government that's kind of
what I was wanting to know like when did
it get started so 1539 the idea came
about like first time using a dictionary
Pierre Joseph prouden adopted Anarchy
and Anarchist in his 1840 treaties what
is property and then it goes into
explaining the rest of us but go ahead
you were going to say something about
Anarchy with a relationship a friend
just because the word was used for the
first time in a certain year does not
mean the concept or the philosophy was
original to that year of time I'll give
you examples of anarchism working music
Cuisine mathematics astronomy these are
all Anarchist systems meaning there is
no Sovereign there's no government
regulating it these are individuals and
organizations working together
voluntarily and creating systems those
are all examples of working Anarchist
systems
can that be uh uh can those philosophy
so so for you if Anarchy is a
relationship and it's used in those
different uh sects
then then what would be an ideal
situation for you for there to not be a
government well I don't I know about
ideal because I think when you start
getting into ideals it starts becoming a
little bit incoherent but yes and not
necessarily not be a government but the
understanding that the government is
inherently illegitimate and frankly a
lot of what the government does and I'm
sorry I have my back to you by the way
uh a lot of what the government does is
a function of so many people being
trained to regard it as legitimate and
basically bend the knee when they should
otherwise have to so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]